let's start this way so you know we had
the new york times story that came out
almost four years ago and so much has
changed with the topic since then you've
been involved with it for a long time as
an observer give me your general sense
of where we are now um because there are
exciting developments on multiple fronts
i worry that it becomes ufo uab overload
for the public but give me give me your
sense of where we are now well actually
the one thing i would probably not agree
with is that it's overload for the
public because the public i talked to
doesn't seem to be that aware of it i
have to sort of bring people up to speed
and and tell them what's going on um
but in general
i think
you'd have to
be a crank yourself to not believe that
four years later we've made progress
there is more progress there is more
general acceptance and there are more
people who are talking about it in a
serious legitimate way um i don't know
that that means we're eminently
uh
in in uh standing at the door of a of a
big shift maybe we are um but i feel
like a big shift has already happened in
that you know
both you and myself have been involved
in this for a number of years and i've
never seen it at this point where
there's more things that are sort of
breaking in a
in a more public and uh non-uh ufo way
where there the mainstream media seems
to be covering it people are writing
articles there's a lot more going on so
yeah i think things are changing a
little bit i really do
we saw some pretty amazing things over
the last week and a half or so
one that jumps out at me is senator
gilbrand of new york has proposed an
amendment to some other pretty amazing
proposed legislation can you talk about
that when you read that what were your
first reaction to it was i my first
reaction when i read about the gila
brand amendment was that it felt like a
blue book 2.0 but with a with some teeth
in it uh if they passed it as was and as
written so i i think it's a positive
thing uh clearly it was a positive thing
when they put the last 180 day clock in
that got us the uap uh task force report
and i think uh this this will be a good
thing if it passes anywhere close to the
the way the amendment is currently
drafted
um i look at it as a as a super positive
uh i i i don't want to look to the
government for all the answers because
the government has historically kept
this from a lot of these answers so i
can't get
a hundred percent excited about the
government doing it but i think what it
does is it kind of unleashes some other
powers that are out there
but first reaction
very very positive uh thinking it's it's
about damn time
and uh if it if it is passed in anything
that references what is written a good
thing i mean one of the things they're
talking about doing is actively going
out and looking into cases and then
filing reports well that does sound a
little bit like blue book but it sounds
a little more serious it sounds more
authentic
and also you know talking about
do we have
technological materials and and have
people been made ill by uh exposure to
uap i've it's just i mean the box has
been opened and things are coming out of
it it sounds to me like the senator or
someone on her staff has been doing a
lot of reading because
this goes way beyond the other proposed
legislation that seems to have
bipartisan support let's establish
something a successor to the uap task
force a permanent program that by itself
is amazing but it really was looking at
sensor data military encounters similar
to what atip supposedly do this
gillibrand is talking about something
closer to awesome looking at human
effects and follow the evidence where it
leads which is astonishing
not only is it astonishing but i think
what was astonishing to me to go back to
that what my first think was
senator gillibrand what's up with that i
mean i i had not
been given a hint that she was involved
or might be involved in this kind of
world so
uh that gives me hope too it means that
there are senators out there who have
been exposed to certain briefings who
have paid attention and are are behaving
in a way that is appropriate to some of
the information they're getting um but
yes it does seem more serious i get a
little lost to this day and i admit uh i
admit it and and i think i'm one of the
more informed people out there but i
still get mixed up on asap and atip and
and and i noticed that even in the gila
brand amendment we're going to create a
couple more uh acronyms that will
confuse us all i i you know i was
thinking of just writing an article
frankly that told everybody what each
acronym stands for because uh everybody
needs a cheat sheet these days back when
it was blue book you could at least go
well that's what blue book said now it's
like
i don't know it's a little more it's a
little more challenging yeah i've done
some of that uh in public presentations
where i explain awsap versus atip csa
bass
the various uh competing uh acronyms
tic-tac-toe it's not an acronym but you
can throw it in there as a term that is
not familiar to the general public it
seems to me that you know there's
bipartisan support for something some
kind of an office to have a permanent
investigation even if it's just looking
at military encounters that's a major
step forward at least i hope it would be
do you agree i do agree and also uh
let's face it congress is full of uh
ambitious politicians uh who's been the
most uh probably outspoken on this issue
is marco rubio of all people and and
let's face it he ran for president he's
an ambitious politician he doesn't think
talking about uh uap is going to kill
his career uh he may in fact think that
you can actually run on uab because it's
sort of a threat analysis situation
mitt romney extremely outspoken on it
people are sort of poking their heads
out and talking about it and they're
using the cover right now i think of of
trying to say well you know it could be
anything i just you know but we know
they're real and we want to make sure
it's not our adversaries uh because that
would be a bad thing but i keep saying
if if they're real if they're not
made in america if they're not made by
china or russia then frankly you don't
have to be a high level math student to
do the math on that one it's
you know some kind of exotic technology
that we haven't been privy to knowing
about
you uh you wrote a couple of weeks ago
your reactions to skinwalkers at the
pentagon
came out in the end of that book there
is a very detailed proposal for a
program that sounds remarkably similar
to what the senator from new york is now
proposing it's very similar to what
assap was meaning essentially you follow
the evidence where it leads you don't
just look at things in the sky you don't
just look at radar or sonar sensor
information you follow the evidence
where it leads which leads to people
human effects interactions with these
phenomena whatever they are and often
very deleterious effects health effects
give me your sense of uh what you
learned from that book and whether you
think that somebody at
the senator's office has been reading it
well i think it has been read and by the
way congratulations on the book it broke
a lot of ground a lot of news uh and if
if anything i think it does show you uh
all the acronyms that you had to like
fade your way through to even write that
book uh is actually the flip side the
positive side to it is it means
you know you don't create an acronym out
of nothing it's usually for some kind of
official reason so there were a lot of
people looking into it i think it has
been read and i count myself to be one
of the lucky people who sat down uh with
lunch uh to lunch with you a few years
back and we i think our conversation
turned to that very thing it's like okay
you you start to you know i'm a former
inves i guess i guess you're all once an
investigative reporter you get to claim
that so i've been that you are that
currently um
but you you follow the facts you start
to you don't have even if you have a
preconceived notion you still have to
have keep your mind open to the idea
that you may not have it right and you
got to be able to get off your position
so um what has happened over the years
clearly is that we've gone from ufo
unidentified flying object which means
let's just look up in the sky and see
what's out there
which was weird enough if it wasn't ours
but now following the facts you start to
see there are effects to those things
and as you point out in the skinwalker
book uh it
it's not just things flying around it's
things that are happening around us and
uh clearly
someday skinwalkers at the pentagon is
going to be looked at as a book that
sort of brings these two worlds together
and and raises the question for all of
us and we're about to learn i think um i
hope in my lifetime officially um that
that there's a big connection to this
and that there's um the world is
stranger than we have imagined and we're
going to have to
open our minds up a little bit and and
try to get our brains involved with
trying to think about what is really
going on
so this time next year there might be a
permanent program approved by congress
funded it's it's starting an
investigation maybe starting from
scratch hopefully building on research
that's already been done but
a grand new adventure a new level of uh
public interest in this topic do you
think
that a program like that studying
military encounters
nuts and bolts flying saucers radar etc
talking to pilots can solve this mystery
or
do you worry that maybe it's going to
always be out of our reach
well i actually my my feeling on that is
either we've already semi sort of solved
the mystery and we're not telling
everybody you know we're not sharing our
work if you will uh at the highest
levels or at least with the public right
now or
the mystery
isn't that easily solved because
the the only
problem i have with the the current
run to do this formal investigation is
we've been there before with blue book
uh of course and now it looks like we're
going to be more serious about it but
there's just so much to know
and and it is important for us to track
these things down but but again we have
to not just only look through the
windshield at the road ahead we got to
turn around and look in that rear view
mirror and say this has been getting
studied for 75 years at least at minimum
sin for 75 years because you and i have
read
you know foia release documents on it so
i
i just still say it it's all great i'm
i'm in favor of it i hope this all moves
forward in a powerful way but i would
like the work shared more diligently for
what has gone before there were there
are lots of people who are not with us
anymore who devoted their lives to
studying this in in government and out
of government and i think it would be
nice if what comes out of this is we
start to bring the whole big picture
together
you know as you mentioned 75 plus years
of uh of interest in the subject but but
not much transparency and we have seen
documents squeezed out of the military
through foia that were never meant to
see the light of day in which the
military officials at the highest levels
are saying this is real it's not
fictitious or imaginary we need to get
in look into this because it could be
considered a threat i mean that's where
we were 75 years ago and in a sense it's
where we are now it is where we are now
but what i think is wonderful the
difference now is if you're if you're
literally compelling the military to to
own up and share their data there's a
lot more data and the data that we have
uh is clearly
of of a better quality i mean our
sensors are
good enough to tell us if we're being
attacked uh you know by a weapon from
somebody uh you know a nuclear weapon
coming over the poles our our sensors
are really good and they're picking up
stuff uh that that hasn't been picked up
historically and and obviously those
those sensors aren't just uh
spread around the earth they're on each
aircraft we we have literally thousands
of ways to gather data about uap and
one of the exciting things about the
gila brand amendment or whatever comes
out of it
and and what comes out of the the june
25th report earlier is a sense that we
have to start sharing this data that we
can't make the same mistake we made with
terrorism where everybody had it siloed
into their respective organizations and
it took 911 for us all to come together
and start sharing that data i think
we're going to start sharing uap data
right now
some groups will be more forthcoming
than others obviously for example it
doesn't take a a brain surgeon to figure
this out the navy has been a lot more
open to talking about it than the air
force and i would like to know why yeah
you know i i hope the next step after
these things is people like gillibrand
or or the senate intel committee start
hauling air force people in and saying
why didn't you cooperate you know what
is your
assessment where where is your
information so i think we need a few
good senators and congress people to
kick the can here and and uh find out
what's underneath yeah you you notice at
the end of that that uap task force
report we saw some language about the
air force that they are now going to
establish some some listening posts
where they can check out and look
specifically look for uh these
unidentifieds uaps call them whatever
you want but it's the sense i get is
they had to be drag kicking and
screaming to even get that far
that they are are not all that
interested in transparency or
on the surface at least not that
interested in the topic and it suggests
to me as as we covered in the skin
walkers of the pentagon there are forces
out there that are are going to fight
this every step of the way you know
there you read between the lines in the
book
the guys from awsap went
to knock at the door of where they think
the goodies are hidden and they got told
to go away and the door was slammed in
their face um someone somewhere out
there has a lot more information and
maybe even physical evidence and uh i
think as we get closer
they're going to put up even more of a
fight you know george we're also going
to need a another acronym i hate to be
the guy that say it but ufo wasn't quite
it but neither is uap unidentified
aerial phenomena it's part of it but
what about these things in the ocean you
know that's not aerial phenomena uh what
about the things that you and your uh
your
fellow investigators discovered at
skinwalker and what's going on at
skinwalker not always aerial phenomena
other kinds of phenomena
i i do believe that there will come a
time when we look back at these days and
we realize uh that we were kind of naive
and that the the real answer is the
universe is not only stranger than we
imagined but possibly stranger than we
can imagine and that that when even our
and that even our smartest minds someday
are still going to say
this is my best guess not sure
you know we're not quite there yet it's
going to take a while
i've heard some feedback from people
whose opinions i value uh who have been
involved in lobbying congress behind the
scenes to try to get them to be
interested in this and take a fair look
at it they are concerned about wu about
uh exactly the kind of phenomena that
the gillibrand amendment would would uh
would involve uh because you know
there's one thing to study nuts and
bolts saucers in the sky things that can
be picked up on sensors things that
appear over military installations
a really good solid reason to pursue
that but there's all this other stuff on
the outside that comes along for the
ride whether you like it or not and
there's concern that if we do look at
the broad picture like the gila brand
amendment would do at things like
skinwalker
at uh poltergeist type things that pop
up at cattle mutilations that it
endangers the whole process that
no one's going to approve public money
to study something like that even though
it's part of the story whether we like
it or not i don't i don't uh buy that i
think
you know you're talking about the woo
factor that where people are like wow i
was up for talking about it when we were
talking about
physical craft flying around but now
you've you've lost me because you're
going i i just think that the horse is
out of the barn on this thing all right
we've acknowledged to ourselves
officially that these things are real
now we have an obligation to look into
what that means and if the search for
what that means leads to having to
accept a little woo in our lives then
then that then i'm sorry uh tough break
uh for the people that find that to be
too challenging uh ultimately uh they
may slow things down at the beginning
because i you know listen
i've got i've got i've got a new class
of friend right now and i think this
bears on your question the new class of
friend is the they used to treat me like
the drunk uncle at the wedding right
that okay there's bryce talking about
ufos and then i i don't get that as much
anymore i get that more from people who
now i get from people
tell me what you know right but there's
a new class of friend that actually
knows a little bit about it
and says i just uh you know i just um
boy i just don't want to think about it
okay well it so if that's a new class
that's being created yes you're right
george there will be people in congress
who fall into that category and there'll
be people congress is still a reflection
of us bad as that is uh and some of the
people will be nuts and bolts people and
some will be woo people and some people
will be uh don't talk to me about that
people i remember
in studying the early days of ufology
those guys like kehoe and others are are
fine with studying flying saucers but
they were reluctant to say there might
be somebody in those flying saucers
sipping around that there might be
aliens in there and then years later
they're very reluctant these are ufo
people reluctant to say those aliens in
the craft are interacting with us may be
abducting us i mean it's been tough to
even drag ufologists along on this trip
it has it's been a it's been a continual
struggle
and if you think about it
here's what i think the evolution we're
going to see over the next
10 years
right now we're in a period where the
way to discuss this seems to be at least
officially is
we need to understand we know these
things are real but we need to
understand what's behind them and and
implied in that is it might be
us you know they may be made in america
or made by our adversaries we've got to
rule that out
over the next few years we are going to
rule that out all right and at that
point the conversation it will be a
different conversation that conversation
is going to be about
well
uh they're here they're they're not us
uh what are our theories and that's
where i want to get our best minds out
there instead of going well is it china
or is it russia or is it us instead
they're going to say
is it et
is it
dimensional is it time is it you know i
and i don't i don't have a horse in that
race right now and i don't think you do
either we would just like
the best minds instead of pretending
it's not happening to acknowledge it is
and then try to decide what it might be
and to help us as a society and i'll
tell you just one thing that i've always
believed that i think is going to bear
on this and that is simply it's a simple
statement but all of us together are
smarter than any one of us
all right so until we start looking at
this as a large group uh the entire
society looking at it marshalling our
best minds our best information our best
data we won't get the best theories and
the best answers so
what's going to be good about the next
few years is we're going to usher in a
new period of seriousness
and that's good
last week there was another event that
got a lot of attention
on the international stage there was an
event in washington
uh where the dni the director of
national intelligence was there for the
conversation jeff bezos one of the
richest men in the world abby loeb
astronomy professor at harvard um
talking about walking right up to the
edge of talking about extraterrestrials
and i i don't think there's anything
particularly newsworthy that came out of
that
other than you know it seems like jeff
bezos doesn't really know what he's
talking about when it comes to the
subject but
the fact that it happened at all and
that people of that caliber of that
stature were willing to discuss it to an
extent
is speaks volumes about our times now
yeah i i listen um i'm happy like you
are that it happened uh i was not a fan
of it i didn't think it was well done
i i had to tear my fists out of the
ceiling a few times i thought that david
ignatius failed as a journalist and
showed absolutely no intellectual
curiosity about what what he was
involved in he seemed to phone it in and
i was upset with them um i do think the
two first people are are brilliant
people uh
avril haynes uh the
director of national intelligence is
definitely somebody you should put on a
show for three hours and drill deep and
ask her what she knows david ignatius
could care less um
and i'll tell you the the new star in my
universe is um
you know is the head of nasa uh because
bill nelson uh a former astronaut former
senator is the only person actually
willing to say well it might be e.t you
know i'm willing to consider that i'm
willing to look into it
as for the rest of it um listen jeff
bezos i've i've met jeff bezos nice man
i'm glad he's doing what he's doing uh
you know bringing people up into space
i think he's either
ill-informed or is one of those people
that does it doesn't suit his version of
reality to talk about that these might
be real because he's more about building
ships to get us into space not to find
people coming here same with uh you know
avi uh avi writes for my uh trail of the
saucers publication i'm glad to have him
uh but he just tiptoes up to it and
again i don't know if pointing you know
my uh telescopes at the sky is gonna be
the big thing uh i i
i tend to think it probably won't but
especially since we have evidence that
they're here in our in our own skies i
think we should be pointing more around
that so that's kind of my take
um so i was disappointed it could have
been so much more and i look forward to
a time when we put those kind of people
on with a journalist like yourself
frankly or or whoever the networks have
who's really informed on the topic and
is a dog with a bone you know i remember
tim russert on on meet the press tim
rosser would ask a question and if
somebody didn't answer it he'd ask it
again and if they still didn't answer it
he'd go i'm sorry but i've asked this
question twice i'm going to ask it again
we'll be here all night if this
continues we need some of those people
well again like i had the same sort of
reaction i was disappointed with the
actual content but i found it
encouraging that people of that stature
would be on that stage and be willing to
talk about it to some extent and maybe
it sets the stage for the next round um
let me ask you about you so you've been
involved in the topic as a writer and
reporter for a long time what's going on
with you in the entertainment
sphere um i hear rumors about all kinds
of projects and pitches and ideas and so
what do you got going and what do you
hear about the larger universe of
entertainment with regard to this topic
listen i think in the entertainment
business a lot of people are interested
in this they read the news like
everybody else but a lot of
entertainment people i what i am
frustrated about personally is that i
keep running into people who who go yeah
i heard about that and their best
way to deal with it would be like apple
tvs
invasion right so in other words you
watch apple tv's invasion and it looks
like the only time anybody ever thought
about aliens is when they invaded you
know there's no sense that there was a
history or there were ufos or any of
that stuff so if you ask me what i'm up
to and what i'm building on on my board
here and things i'm taking out i'm
trying to be the guy
that uh at least in the entertainment
product is writing the stuff that is is
detail-based that could that it that
yeah still a hugely entertaining thing
but that lives in the real world so for
example uh one of my current projects is
i've written a one-hour drama pilot
called uap
which is
very
ground-based accurate but then sort of
going out from there it's kind of i
don't know house of cards meets aliens i
guess in its own way and uh yeah i'll
make a little news here uh we just uh
brought christopher mellen on as our
consultant uh you know to help us set up
this script and he would be sort of our
lawrence o'donnell if you will uh
lawrence o'donnell famously was on west
wing in the first season uh so you know
i'm very proud to have chris mellon
doing that that's a good thing and i'm
finding a lot of interest i mean i'll
tell you one thing you know i'm not a
huge believer in metrics and all that
but i do have this publication on medium
trail of the saucers and it's just
skyrocketing i mean the every every day
you get more
views than you did the day before every
month is better than the last month uh
it's just one of those things where
uh if you build that they will come and
why are they coming it's not that i'm
you know
the numbers don't matter to me but why
are they coming they're coming because
people are hungry to have this
discussion in a serious way so if you
ask me what i'm up to i want to tell
stories that are based in truth i have a
feature film
based on the roswell investigation um i
have a another series on taking out
based on the betty and barney hill case
based on a book i've optioned things
like that but it's very hard i'm not
going to say i'm out there selling every
other day because most of the time when
i go to some place it turns out they've
already got their own project
right
and they'll say what a script man that
thing really well boy fantastic um yeah
but we're doing something similar
so yeah so that's good i mean one more
question about your adventures dark
skies terrific series thank you a lot of
people now you know the modern audience
may not know about it
is there a chance that that comes back
at some point it could but
you know what that was my dream for
years this was the late 90s uh sci-fi
our drama on nbc that uh basically told
the story of of an invasion but it was
told uh against the backdrop of the
1960s so it's become kind of a cult hit
over the years
and uh and i'm very proud of him
extremely proud of it but i felt after
we did 20 hours it was cancelled so i
always felt like i didn't get to finish
telling the story and i would do
anything to continue to tell that story
including rebooting it doing anything to
do it
um
i've had to kind of give that dream up a
little bit because it turns out you know
that i don't own it i mean that's what
it this isn't like britain where they
have different copyright laws here in
order for me to write my idea dark skies
i had to basically sell the copyright to
sony to do it so sony owns dark skies so
whether it ever gets rebooted or not
isn't up to me if it was up to me i'd
have rebooted it two decades ago but uh
but it's it's not up to me so what i'm
concentrating on instead is to say you
know
it doesn't do me any good to follow my
dream
of bringing that particular thing back
because i can't do it by myself but what
i can do is create new original material
and i'm still the same writer i was that
did that so i just tried to say
what can i do that that
is better for the conversation and
frankly i think uap is the best thing
i've i've written on this topic ever uh
because it's so current it's just so
it's something i couldn't do on dark
skies right now because uh dark skies
actually took a position this is what's
going on and uap is about people who are
empowered in our own national government
and still don't know what's happening
right and how they're they're kind of
fumbling their way toward an answer
which i think is what's going on in our
government right now well i'm a fan of
dark skies
i have it at home i'm also a fan of
x-files of course and you know that show
came back for two last seasons
and i loved it but the public didn't and
i wonder if it did it failed because the
real world has gone beyond what the
x-files uh would propose to examine in a
fictional sense i think that's true uh i
i agree 100 with that
first of all i can't for me to criticize
the x-files is a little uh persnickety
on my part because we're on at the same
time i love x-files like like a lot of
people and i enjoyed what it did but if
you'll recall x-files was never all in
on ufos it it basically did a ufo
episode every so often
and they had to create what they called
their mythology right so their mythology
i wouldn't say it got calcified but it
got codified if you will from season to
season to season so by the time you were
watching those last two seasons that
they put on most recently
it was hard to pivot to bring their
mythology in to what is going on and
that's always going to be a problem with
trying to
bring something from the past to life
again although hollywood loves to do
that um
but let's face it this story is big
enough crazy enough
that there's there's room to talk about
a lot of things and i just have one
weird thing that i'll throw out there
which is the first thing i ever wrote
was something called official denial and
not the first thing i ever wrote but the
with the first ufo piece i wrote it was
a two-hour film it was on the sci-fi
channel their first original film
and um
you know one of the things i posited was
that they weren't
aliens they were us from the future and
now of course that seems to be a theory
everybody's talking about yes yes and i
remember writing it in 1988 and showing
it to a few people and they're like what
have you been smoking man because that
just sounds pretty crazy but now people
are willing because i think we all know
that something's happening here and as
the song goes what it is ain't exactly
clear
and so we are wide open right now to
trying to think about and to puzzle
through this mystery together which is
why i've enjoyed uh knowing you and and
and your work so much because
we're both kind of there's a lot of
people
currently it's dark out there we're
fumbling around trying to shine a
flashlight here and there because we
want to get a picture of where we are
but all we ever get at one point is just
that that one illuminated area maybe
that's a little of area 51. oh well
here's this witness and i one of my
favorite essays i ever wrote was how do
we reconcile all this
and and that's what i think to circle
back to where we started this thing you
got ufos you got skinwalker ranch you
got things in the water you got crop
circles you got animal mutilations you
got nuclear power uh
overflies you got tic tacs
what
what would explain all of that at the
same time i don't know
one last question somewhat unrelated
beetle big time for the beatles we share
that interest i i saw some clips there
was something on 60 minutes last night
yes and the footage that peter jackson
is working with is
astounding
it's it is astounding you're talking
about the let it be sessions of course
where uh they were called get back at
that the time it became the let it be
album and famously there was a two-hour
documentary made that uh
showed the beatles just sour and
breaking up but it turns out that
jackson has gone back in found all this
footage uh 60 hours of it and it shows
that they still had a pretty good time
with each other most of the time and i
think that's lovely but i will say this
that's
i think the mind-blowing part of it is
he's managed to take that footage and
bring it to life digitally and on you
know it's the cleanest
sounding the best looking stuff and i
will only tell you this because you know
i uh i wrote a book about the beatles a
few years ago what if if they'd never
broke up it was called once there was a
way and while i was researching that
because basically i took the pivot where
in in our timeline during get back they
break up and in my timeline they figure
out how to keep going right so
i had to study the breakup period
to a high degree which included the get
back sessions that peter jackson of
course is now putting on and i could not
find a good copy of let it be
anywhere it wasn't on vhs it wasn't on
dvd i had to
buy a copy of dd
let it be
off amazon that somebody in singapore or
something had
videoed off a television screen
that was the best i could get of it so
am i thrilled about what we're about to
see six new hours of this yeah and i
wish i was watching it with you because
you're right the the beatles is i think
the beatles illustrate something for
both of us george we both love the ufo
world we've we've enjoyed the mystery uh
we're
driven by our curiosity about it but we
didn't check our humanity at the door we
still we still have reasons to love
things like the beatles we still love a
good movie that's not about ufos we love
our families we love a good restaurant
you know
you're not done being a human being just
because you you care about solving this
giant mystery so yeah i love i love the
beatles and i i'm so excited about what
he's done with can't wait bryce thank
you always great to talk to you we'll be
in touch thank you all right bye-bye
a lot of times
[Music]